welcome back to las vegas now so life is
too short to have boring hair right
that's my motto but you got to keep that
hair looking good and here to help us do
just that is the owner of comey hair
salon stella de giovianni did i get that
right
saying such a beautiful name and you
obviously have beautiful hair thank you
so much for being here thank you let's
talk about the salon you said you're at
the gramercy and i was like you know
what i haven't seen your salon i think
it's fairly recent you just opened a few
months ago tell us about what you guys
specialize in and what people can expect
when they come in so we specialize in
hair extensions first and foremost and
we also are a guest experience salon so
it's not just your average just get in
come and get your hair done the entire
salon is based on
an experience and providing like an
elevated experience for our guests i
love that yeah if you're going to come
in and get your hair done you're in that
chair for a while so you want to feel
like you're in a relaxed and cool
environment and let's talk because we're
in the winter season and our hair
obviously kind of changes as each season
comes along so do you have some tips for
keeping our hair looking fresh and good
absolutely so during the winter season a
lot of things happen
first of all there's more humidity so we
tend to have a lot more frizz as women
and our hair actually does get drier
because of the constant change in the
temperature so we always recommend
making sure you're doing more of a
moisture mask during those seasons we
love our orbe moisture mask it's just
amazing it makes your color look super
vibrant and it also protects against
frizz and smooths the hair cuticle down
so you have less frizz
we all need that let me tell you
yes as women absolutely
and and then you have here which i i'm
interested to learn more about because i
know that even pillowcases and certain
things can really you know make or break
your hair so what tips do you have as
far as it comes to satin and those types
of materials so we always recommend
either a silk or satin pillow case but
also one thing people don't think about
is during the winter we're actually
wearing a lot more coats okay so what
happens is we
tend to tangle a lot more throughout
here so if you were to take just a satin
scarf and you just wrap it around your
neck it's actually going to prevent you
to have much much less tangles so that
way when you comb your hair out you're
not breaking all these pieces off
because if you ever noticed when you go
into the summer months give a ton of
broken hair yeah that's actually
probably because you were brushing and
it has the friction at the back of your
coat um so doing that and using a satin
pillowcase scarf is going to prevent any
of those unnecessary breakages tell you
you're speaking to me right now i always
do that with my hair especially in the
winter and you don't even realize you're
doing it and just before we wrap up i'm
someone who's been coloring my hair my
whole life but maybe taking a step back
during the winter could actually help
the healthiness of it right absolutely
because during the summer months we tend
to go a little bit brighter a little bit
blonder so the winter months are the
perfect opportunity
to either make a subtle shift in your
tonality and kind of do that more
lived-in look that everybody's been
trying lately yeah it's the perfect time
to give your hair a break so that way
you're not damaging it throughout the
entire year and only just for a few
months well stella thank you so much
these are great tips going into the new
year weekend you know new year new you
new hair i love it and if people want to
come check out the salon do you
recommend you know calling and making an
appointment or just stopping by
absolutely we are by appointment only
because we are service based salon and
so go ahead and go to our website
comeyhairsalon.com
we also have an instagram it's comey dot
hair salon and that's we're probably
most active so if you find us on that
we'll definitely reach back out to you
perfect thank you so much and you are
just hair goals i have to say
i guess i'm